Last summer, after sixteen years of absence,
I went to the city in Russia where I grew
up. I went there on company business. And I was bringing with me a suit
case filled with secondhand clothes that my
mom asked me to distribute among her relatives there. I was really the first
in my family to go back there after all those years.
And she also gave me a hand-drawn map showing the location of my grandfather's grave
at a local cemetery, and she asked me to go
there. And when I was leaving, she asked me again. 'Are you going to go there?' 'Yes.'
'Promise?'
'Promise.' It was really important for her that I go there. My grandfather died when I
was little and, she wanted me to remember him. She would tell me stories
about him. I guess it was all a part of dealing with the loss. He was still very
much alive in her
mind. And she wanted him to continue to live in my
mind too. But I was just too little when it all happened, so I didn't remember
much. So I thought maybe this visit to his grave at the
cemetery, for her, would make things up; Would
make up for what she thought was her loss, her failure in keeping his memory
alive. So I promised that the first thing I do when I get there will be go to the cemetery.
Well, the first thing I did when I got there was locate my high school girlfriend.
And I got caught up in work, and I had a lot of catching up to do with my childhood
friends. So it wasn't until a day before I was leaving, that I actually found time to go
to the cemetery. And it was late in the afternoon. And right by the
entrance was a woman who was selling flowers.
And by then, she only had seven carnations left in her pocket. And I bought them all.
But when I reached for my wallet, I realized I didn't have the map with me. I
had no idea what happened to that map, and I had no idea where my grandfather's grave was
located. I could call my mom and ask her. There was
a payphone right there and I still had ten or fiftenn minutes left on my calling
card and it was already morning in New York. But the problem was, I had already told her that
I went to the
cemetery. And,
really, you know, what was I gonna say? That I decided to go again but lost the map? She knows who she's
Dealing with, she'd see right through it.
So I thought I'd find some help. And I went to look for the main
office. And I found the main office and, it was actually in the middle of the cemetery
and it occupied an actual family mausoleum. So I
figured some... some affluent family must have immigrate...  must have commissioned it for
themselves but then maybe immigrated to the United States, or the management
took advantage of the opportunity and moved right
in. And, uh, fortunately for me it was open,
and inside was a small office,
filled with file cabinets. It kind of looked like a financial aid office at some community college.
And behind the counter was an old woman, she was reading. And she said yes she'd help me
locate my grandfather's
records. And she started looking in those file cabinets. And she was doing everything so slowly.
I knew it was going to take forever. And then the back room door opened and the little
boy walked in, an eight-year-old, I think.
And he said, 'Grandma. I don't want to play anymore let's go home.' And I could see through
the door that there was a computer in the back room with Pac-Man or something like that on the
screen. And she says, 'Do Grandma a favor. Go do a grave
identification search, the name is Abraham ?Pikarsky?.' And the boy says, 'Yes. Should
I look in the mass graves too?' And she turns to me and she says, 'Did you say he died
in the war?' 'No, he died in the early
seventies.' So. The boy went back inside, and a couple of minutes later, he comes
back with a printout.
And I was gonna reach for it but the boy's grandmother says 'No, no, no, let me see it first, it's five
dollars per
grave.' And I'd say, 'Well, is there more than one?' She says
'Yes, there is always more than one.' So it turned out, there were seventeen
Abraham ?Pikarskys? on the list. And I paid
for two.
The two who died in the early seventies, and
whose age, I believe, closely matched my grandfather's.
And I went to look for them. I was hoping that at least one of
them would have a portrait on the tombstone. At least it is the
custom with Russian immigrants here in New York to put portraits on tombstones.
So, I thought, this way I'll know which grave is mine. And I was
walking through the
cemetery, and lots of tombstones have
portraits on them, and I was looking at
the faces. And I was thinking that the faces I saw there didn't look quite
as happy as the faces that I see on our Russian tombstones here in Brooklyn.
So I thought that maybe to have immigrated wasn't such a bad thing after all.
Maybe... maybe all those immigrants did find that happiness that they went after.
So I found the first grave and it said Abraham ?Pikarsky? on it.
But there was no
portrait. It was an inscription from the loving wife and children.
I had no idea whether this was the right one or not, so I went to look for the
other one.
I found it too, and that one was virtually indistinguishable from the first one.
Even the granite was of the same color. It said Abraham ?Pikarsky?, no portrait,
The inscription was slightly different, it said from the grieving family. So I'd really
no idea what to do. Was my family the loving
one or the grieving one? I
was standing there. And I was... and I was waiting. I was thinking maybe some sort of a
special feeling would come to me. I thought maybe I'd feel... I'd feel some sort of
a kinship with the person who was laying
there. But I just... I just kept wondering whether this wasn't a total
stranger who was buried there. I tried to remember all
I knew about my grandfather. He
was... He was a locksmith, he was a father of three. One of
them died in the war. He was a soccer fan, he died from a heart attack. Who
was this Abraham ?Pikarsky??
A dentist? An ?oil? accident victim? I
really didn't know. I put three carnations on the grave. And I went back to the first one.
I stood there too for a
while, and again I was hoping that I'd feel something
special, but it was getting late and I remembered that I had yet to
pack for the
trip back to New York, so I put three more carnations, well I put three
carnations on this
grave. And I stood there with the last flower in my hands, and I
didn't really know what to do with that one.
Which Abraham ?Pikarsky? should it go to? Should I just get rid it, should I take a flower from
another grave maybe and make sure
that each Abraham ?Pikarsky? gets the equal number of flowers.
I had to... I couldn't leave. I had to come up with some sort of a formula.
And then suddenly I knew what to do. I put that flower on
that same grave where I was standing.
I thought if this is really my grandfather who's laying there, then all is well
and
good. And he got the most. But if not, then let this be a
consolation to the stranger. Because it wasn't his, but somebody else's grandson, who
came all the way from America to pay his respects. And I laughed. I
went to the hotel. And I never found that map again.
I flew back to New York the next day. Mom and Dad picked me up at the
airport. They have this thing about picking me up at airports. Really.
I would have been home at least an hour sooner, if it wasn't for them.
First they couldn't find the parking.
Then they went to look for me at the wrong terminal, then they lost each
other... finally, finally I found them.
I found them, and on the way on the way home from the airport, in the car my mom started crying.
And I asked, 'Mom why are you crying? It's only been a week.' And she says, 'I'm just
so happy that you took the time to visit your grandfather's grave, it really means so much to me.
I appreciate it. You know when you called and told me you went there, I thought you were
just saying it to make me to make me feel good.' But, but this morning, when I was still
in the air, her second cousin, who still lives in Russia,
called
her and told her that she had just come from the cemetery and that she saw my flowers there. So
my mom really knew that I went there. And she stopped crying and she
was sitting there and she was wiping her eyes. And I was thinking, should
I ask her
how
many... how many
flowers her second
cousins saw: three or four?
But then decided that maybe I should just not say anything at all. Thank
you.